In 2019, you’d probably have to stumble
across a group of scientists to hear people
casually talking about antibodies.
Now, discussions of antibodies and immune
response are dinner table conversation.
You might have seen little Y-shaped representations
of antibodies in news articles, but what do
they /really/ look like, and how do they help
us to fight off infection?
In this lesson, I’ll touch on the importance
of antibodies, examine their structure in
detail, and visualize how they interact with
and neutralize a viral protein.
Let’s get started!
Antibodies are proteins produced by B-cells
that are part of our immune systems.
Antibodies bind to antigens, which is something
the body recognizes as foreign, like a bacteria,
virus, or allergen.
The threat doesn’t even need to come from
outside.
On a small scale, antibodies can bind to a
tumor cell and facilitate its destruction,
and this is the basis for some cancer treatments.
These Y-shaped molecules bind antigens at
the tips of two identical arms.
The rest of the antibody is made up of constant
domains.
The repeated patterns of protein structure
in the constant domains are conserved—that
is, they’re the same—in antibodies of
the same class, and there are five of these
antibody classes, or /isotypes/.
You might be wondering how the body can recognize
a foreign substance that it’s /never/ encountered
before.
Well, the amino acid sequence where the antibody
binds the antigen, at the tips here, is variable.
While the B-cell is developing, the genes
that code for the antigen binding region,
which I’ve coloring slightly lighter here,
are shuffled up like a deck of cards.
This produces many different amino acid sequences
in this region here, called the variable domain.
Each B-cell therefore produces a unique antibody,
but all antibodies produced by that specific
B-cell are the same.
The first antibodies the B-cell produces are
attached to the cell surface, and if that
B-cell happens to bind an antigen, it can
be stimulated to produce more antibodies,
some of which can float freely in our bloodstream
and lymphatic systems.
With that in mind, let’s take a deep dive
into antibody structure.
This is an immunoglobulin G, or IgG antibody
that we’re looking at here.
IgG is the main antibody in the blood, and
the only one that can cross the placenta,
transferring immunity from a mother to a fetus.
The antibody is made up of four different
protein chains, two identical /light/ chains,
shown here in magenta.
The two larger chains, shown in blue, contain
more amino acid residues and are therefore
heavier than the light chains.
These /heavy/ chains meet up to form a region
called Fc.
Within the Fc, there are two identical carbohydrate
chains, bound to the protein through a covalent
bond with the side chain of an asparagine
amino acid residue.
In addition to stabilizing the immunoglobulin
structure, these carbohydrates may play a
role in antibody secretion and antigen elimination.
Focusing on the antigen binding region for
a moment, let’s recolor the antibody to
show the domain that binds the antigen in
a softer color scheme, but still show the
coloring of the heavy and light chains.
Notice both the heavy and light chain contribute
to the variable domain that binds the antigen.
Now, there’s a repeating structural motif
throughout the entire protein.
This is the immunoglobulin fold.
I’ll apply a new color scheme to highlight
each of the 12 immunoglobulin folds in this
structure.
Let’s focus in on a single motif to examine
the fold in detail.
The beta sheets twist and tangle, which makes
it challenging to really understand the fold
when it’s a solid color.
I’ll apply a rainbow color scheme, and let’s
reorient this structure so we can follow the
motif from the N-terminus to C-terminus.
Conveniently, with the cartoon representation,
we just need to follow the arrows!
The immunoglobulin fold is made up of about
110 amino acid residues that form two tightly
packed antiparallel beta sheets.
Starting with the blue N-terminal beta strand,
A, we can follow the secondary structure through
a short helical segment into strand B, shown
in cyan, a light blue.
Now we twist around into strand C, which connects
to the short strand D through a flexible loop.
Twisting back around, strand E connects to
strand F through a short 3,10-helix.
We find the seventh strand, strand G, at the
C-terminus.
Finally, there is a disulfide bond covalently
linking two cysteine residues in the B and
F β-strands.
This is the form of the immunoglobulin fold
in every one of the constant domains.
The immunoglobulin fold is slightly different
in the variable domains.
Let’s check out one of those!
Applying the rainbow color scheme once again,
and focusing on the N-terminal beta strand,
Here’s strand /A/.
A flexible loop connects this to strand B,
and again, we’ll need to rotate our structure
to see the connection to strand C, shown in
blue green.
Now, there’s quite a difference.
This strand connects to two additional strands,
which are named, by convention, C’ and C’’.
These continue into strands D and E, which
link around to strands F and G, shown in orange
and red at the C-terminal end.
There are nine strands in the variable domain
immunoglobulin fold, compared to seven in
the constant domains.
And here’s the disulfide bond linking the
B and F strands.
Antibody structure is cool and all, but seeing
an antibody interact with an antigen is /really/
interesting.
So, let’s take a peek at the antibody–antigen
interaction that’s made the immune system
a topic of casual conversation, and explore
a human antibody that binds to the SARS-CoV-2
coronavirus spike protein.
The spike protein is located on the surface
of the SARS-CoV-2 virus.
It binds to the ACE-2 receptor on human cells
to cause infection.
I’ve got a video on this interaction if
you want to check it out, but this video is
focused on antibodies.
Here, we’re looking at a side view of the
spike protein, and let’s switch from surface
representation to cartoon to view specific
interactions more easily.
Here’s the spike protein with an antibody,
but this isn’t the real structure.
I’ve overlapped the whole antibody we were
looking at before with the antibody that binds
to spike to help you orient yourself to this
structure.
You see, when studying proteins, structural
biologists rarely look at the entire antibody
because it’s difficult to get a good resolution
structure and see everything clearly.
Instead, many antibodies are cleaved in specific
locations using protease enzymes, and the
structure is solved with an antibody fragment.
A specific protease named papain will cleave
the antibody right about here, lopping off
the two antigen-binding fragments, called
Fabs for short.
The Fab consists of the variable domains from
both the heavy and light chain, plus a constant
domain from each, all conveniently held together
by the disulfide bonds that make up the immunoglobulin
fold.
After the protein is cleaved, the Fc domain
can be separated from the Fab domains, and
the Fabs alone are used in the binding experiment.
Oh and by the way, Fc stands for “crystallizable
fragment”—when researchers had just started
to study the cleavage of antibodies with proteases,
they found that this fragment was easy to
crystallize.
Coming back to the structure at hand, let’s
switch over to the actual antibody Fab that’s
bound to spike.
In this structure, there are actually three
Fabs bound in three different regions of the
spike protein.
This particular antibody binds spike in an
inactive conformation, preventing it from
changing to the shape it needs to adopt to
infect cells.
But, let’s just focus on one Fab to explore
the molecular interactions that allow this
antibody to neutralize spike, and recolor
spike white so the red oxygen atoms will be
easy to see.
Zooming in on the antibody-spike interface,
we’ll show the amino acids that can interact
as sticks.
Some of the interactions stabilizing the structure
are hydrogen bonds, like this short, strong
one that forms between the OH group on tyrosine
and the negatively charged aspartate side
chain.
Remember, in these structures, the hydrogen
atoms aren’t shown.
Another side chain/side chain interaction
that promotes antibody binding is this hydrogen
bond between this negatively charged glutamate
and the hydrogen of the serine hydroxyl group.
Side chain-/backbone/ interactions also promote
binding, like the interaction of this positively
charged lysine with this carbonyl group on
the main protein chain.
Though weaker, van der Waals interactions
are also important in binding, and we see
a network of these dispersion forces driving
the interaction of this phenylalanine on spike
with tyrosine residues on both the heavy and
light chains of the antibody.
Here’s another one, this time between a
phenylalanine from the heavy chain and a tryptophan
on spike.
And another, this time between a tryptophan
and a valine.
Antibody-antigen binding kicks off the immune
response that allows the body to fight infection.
Part of this is the formation of more B-cells
that produce the antibody.
As the B-cells divide, some fine-tuning occurs.
In a process called somatic hypermutation,
the antigen-binding region undergoes additional
mutations, which change some of the amino
acids, particularly in loop regions called
CDRs.
Some of these mutated antibodies won’t bind
at all, but some will bind better, and the
B-cells that produce these superior antibodies
will become long-lived memory B-cells that
can quickly respond to similar antigens in
the future.
Scientists can also facilitate the process
of superior antibody production.
Understanding molecular interactions can help
us engineer antibodies that can serve as antivirals,
antibiotics, and even cancer treatments.